AJA HAMMERLY: Managed
instance groups
are handy when you
need several VMs that
are configured identically.
To create an instance template,
start in the Compute section
on the cloud console.
Click Instance templates,
Create Instance Template.
Name your template.
Pick a machine type.
Update the boot disk if
you need to, and configure
the rest of the
options in the way that
works for your project.
This process is nearly
identical to setting up
a single instance.
Be sure to check the
Allow HTTP Traffic
and Allow HTPS Traffic
Boxes if you need to.
There are additional options,
including the ability
to add an SSH key in the
collapsed section here.
Now, click Create.
To use this template,
you select it in the list
and you click Create
Instance Group.
I hope you found this
Cloud Minute helpful.